peu jeu
seule la parole donnée
moi aussi j'ai une question qui a déjà
le but pardon vu sur vidéo ou assister
d'intervention ma part la génération
habitations directement question qui n'a
jamais vu
le drop passer directement en question
la nature
je vais passer directement aux questions
que je répète toujours embauche de
passer directement question c'est
qu'est-ce qui fait le maître des
questions et si c'est moi
alors j'ai six mois j'ai une requête
l'approché trois fils et la place à
quelqu'un d'autre ou alors bouleversé le
programme mais sinon si la place carnot
vidéo est ce qu'on prend le problème est
je pense que ça sera mieux entendant les
gros pas de sens j'ai un peu du mal
effectivement après les entretiens au
celtic qui nous disent qui par le passé
les plans plutôt à poudre a expliqué
comment l'egypte ancienne
à eux deux
j'ai pas nécessairement vouloir
expliquer tous les réchauffements passer
mais je vais vous expliquer les climato
sceptiques il ya le climato scepticisme
relève d'une seule motivation qui est de
refuser de problèmes parce qu'on a bien
conscience du fait que la solution
valeur contraignante
ou que de refuser de problème ahmed en
soi des avantages de quelques catégories
de le climato sceptiques que je connais
sont les suivantes lyonnais qui est
assez d'eux présente en france mais qui
est très puissante aux états unis qui
sont les gens très croyant qui disent la
marche du monde c'est la sphère de dieu
nous on peut pas toucher au monde ont
pensé qu'on pourrait modifier quoi que
ce soit dans l'environnement c'est
rétention absolument insupportable
devancé par ici il ya une deuxième
catégorie climato-sceptiques qui
appartient aux milieux scientifiques qui
sont les scientifiques qui n'arrive pas
à se faire un nom qui n'arrive pas à se
faire une notoriété sur leur champ de
recherche contre et qui du coup
considère que c'est plus important des
deux fois en racontant des conneries
devant un micro plutôt que de rester
inconnu dans leur domaine une variante
de sa pouvant être déjà reconnues dans
leur domaine voulons être connus partout
et donc si on ne demande pas leur avis
sur tout et tout le temps faim que
cagnard veut et à ce moment de la
logique de la société il ya une
troisième catégorie climato sceptiques
alors toutes les catégories qui sont en
train d'évoquer résiste à toute avancée
scientifique puisque leur motivation n'a
rien à voir avec la science
il ya une troisième catégorie de climato
sceptiques qui sont les gentils dans le
monde économique n'ont pas envie de la
contrainte qui pourraient naître de
l'acceptation du problème alors on les
appelle comme on veut défendre vis et
les ultralibéraux des poissons
du charbon les frontières enfin en gros
c'est une motivation qui est de cet
ordre là et enfin il ya une autre
catégorie de climato sceptiques qui sont
les vieux dirigeants retraités toujours
pour des questions d'ego parce que
accepter le fait qu'il ya un gros
problème qui n'avait pas vu dans leur
carrière et auquel maintenant ils ne
peuvent plus rien faire
en gros on leur dit quelqu'un familier
des voitures italie il pense qu'il ya un
grand bienfaiteur de la population qui
nous a ramené la mobilité pour pas cher
et on lui dit à la fin de sa vie alors
qu'il veut plus rien faire parce qu'il
ya la fête ils convoyaient un truc que
tu as par une secte a aussi contribué à
un tel problème qui est aujourd'hui nous
emmerder ton c'est pas préféré est alors
du coup le réflexe chez ces gens là est
de se dire non quand même je n'ai pas pu
passer à côté d'un truc aussi important
que ça c'est juste pas possible
alors donc je dis que le truc c'est
juste n'importe quoi voilà donc tout
c'est la terre ce sera réchauffée de 4,2
donné que toutes ces criminels toutes
ces théories climato-sceptiques
existeront toujours
ça n'a rien à voir
ni avec la réalité du dossier
scientifique ni avec et donc penser
qu'on va convaincre et aux sceptiques en
le battant sur le terrain de la science
si je tombais de combat vous trois autre
chose derrière
là encore jo c'est encore autre chose
encore autre chose alors c'est pas
inutile de lui répondre quand vous avez
une audience qui par ailleurs est une
audience agnostique parce que l'audience
agnostique reçoit l'argument qui note au
cetic et se dira peut-être c'est
peut-être font des scrutins tech
effectivement on crevait de choses dans
l'egypte ancienne faisait 45 nouvelles à
lombez que voilà donc il faut être
capable d'y répondre mais pour les gens
qui regardent pas pour la personne qui
vous a posé la question car vous avez
l'objection de toute façon ma chambre
pour les commandes en une question par
personne restée très succincte
c'est une expansion des audits la
catégorie des personnes qui pensent que
le climat a toujours changé avec la
principale d'occupation soustraire
or cité détruite donc notre inapte de 12
300 chambres ou les saunas spas pop
enfin pour moi c'est ainsi qu'à une
pondération des inconvénients qui est un
truc est toujours discutable si je vous
dis vous avez en prépa la cervelle est
complètement occupé au problème d'une
fois point de vue voix ou peut-être
peut-être pas enfin bon donc on a en
fait plusieurs problèmes sur les bras en
même temps c'est comme ça qu'ils sont
prêts pour le show
e
je sais pas dans quel ordre les bras se
sont levés en là bas alors là à
l'économie
joie
mais ce
si on
pour examiner dans le besoin c'est d'une
telle approche mais comment est-ce que
vous
déterminer quelle que soit sa essentiels
et les arabes moi je me détermine pas il
ya eu notamment besoin aujourd'hui est
un bon qui est assez fallacieux parce
qu'en fait ils agrègent les vrais
besoins
jean respirer boire manger et dormir
seront pris de genre de choses notre
espérance de vie après de très longues
et ceci n'est que des désirs solvable
par exemple éviter d'en avoir une
chambre à coucher par enfant c'est un
des soldats mais c'est pas un besoin
donc sur vit très bien sans sarah pu
rester soudés sur des spéciales raid a
survécu l'essentiel du temps ça avoir
une voiture pour aller à son boulot qui
est à 10 km c'est pas un besoin que
c'est un désastre table vous pouvez vous
lever une demi heure plus tôt où il a
plutôt y aller à pied le reste les gens
l'ont fait pendant un moment
donc c'est très très difficile dans le
débat sur les besoins de faire la
différence entre ce qu'on considère pas
ce qui est quelque chose qui va vraiment
vous tuer si vous n'avez pas accès
quelque chose qui relève de l'inconfort
et quelque chose qui relève du superflu
c'est d'autant plus difficile du coup
lui de s'accorder donc c'est un bon
qu'il appelle définition normative
c'est ce que je suis en train de vous
dire donc à partir du moment où on
essaye de se mettre d'accord sur une
série discussions sont les besoins de
façon générale une façon que j'en
sortirai jamais on s'intéresse jamais ce
qu'il faut c'est prendre des problèmes
un par un coût et dans les problèmes
brille un par un il faut essayer de
rétablir une préférence
par exemple en ce qui concerne se
déplacer est-ce que c'est plus important
si on
voix assurée l'une des deux choses
suivantes d'assurer d'abord la mobilité
du quotidien devant la mobilité donc
distance il ya il n'y a qu' il n'y a
qu'un seul moyen c'est une préférence
politique tient à partir du moment où si
les gens vous dit je préfère marcher à
pied toute l'année et avoir droit de
prendre une voiture une fois dans
l'année pour partir en vacances et donc
faire inverse c'est-à-dire avoir ma
voiture toute l'année partir et partir
en train là on tombe typiquement dans la
temps la préférence collective donc à
partir du moment où il n'ya pas de
définition normative de toute façon vous
retrouver en général avec une définition
de fait par la préférence politique
là c'est une question un peu différente
ça veut dire que la contrainte ray vous
pouvez lui donner une définition
normative
ce qui est très différent donc le besoin
pas nécessairement
par contre la contrainte oui et tu
restes pour rebondir sur la question qui
a été posée juste avant sur la
biodiversité
une des raisons pour lesquelles le
climat est monté très haut dans les
préoccupations
j'ai envie affichée et dans les
problèmes dont certains s'occupent à
petite vitesse
c'est parce que il a l'énorme avantage
par rapport à la dionyversité d'avoir
une définition normative assez simple il
ya une quantité totale de co2 qu'il faut
pas dépasser dans l'atmosphère si on
veut pas dépasser dette et les patientes
enfin telle élévation de température
les émissions sont totalement fiable
parce que en fait tu voulais de
résidence de co2 dans l'atmosphère est
tellement longue pour ceux qui n'ont
jamais entendu dans les conférences
il faut attendre plus de dix mille ans
pour évacuer un surplus de co2 qu'on va
créer dans l'apostolat donc ça vous
donne une petite idée du côté
irréversible du problème donc le poids
et la cure d'autérité bout d'un siècle
on en a évacué la moitié mais le temps
est tellement long que en fait le lieu
d'émission n'a aucune importance
donc vous avez une idée pottas confond
gigleux sur terre et vous pouvez
comparer les émissions d'un brésilien et
d'un chinois est la biodiversité la
salle abandon du brésil et le panda
c'est en tant qu'homme en comparaissant
est ce que vous les comparez aux points
à la longueur de la dr
véritable donc la raison pour laquelle
on s'est beaucoup occupé de ce problème
là c'est notamment pas seulement c'est
aussi un prêt important mais c'est
notamment parce que là une capacité à
gérer en face on n'a pas nécessairement
avec d'autres problèmes d'environnement
qui sont importants mais pour lesquels
la métrique la tonne d'équivalent
bourduge au nom avant de retrouver le
donc pour la contrainte ça c'est
beaucoup plus facile de faire partager
la contrainte du reste la raison pour
laquelle je suis passé aux questions que
se posent à la vie que j'ai une
intervention pour expliquer ce que c'est
que la contrainte d'appeler déjà tous vu
on a zappé cette partie là mais c'est ça
il ya une définition normative
[Musique]
mentionné
et après
[Musique]
c'est par la préférence politique n'y a
pas d'autres moyens si les gens
préfèrent avoir moins de voitures et
plus de bifteck c
les fans pourquoi pas versus moindre
piste qui est plus une voiture
il ya une expérience qui était bonne il
apparaît évident que j'ai trouvé assez
intéressante la convention citoyenne
pour le climat alors pour moi elle est
doublement intéressante sur les
intéressants sur deux points elle est
intéressante sur un premier point c'est
que quelle que soit la pertinence des
mesures proposées parce qu'il ya
certaines mesures qui sont pas chiffrés
dont on peut dire c'est anecdotique dans
le pour les barrages il ya un point
quand même qu'il commun globalement à
l'ensemble de ce qui a été proposé c'est
que ces dépositions beaucoup plus
radical que ce à quoi l'ensemble de la
population et aujourd'hui enfin
considère aujourd'hui comme légitime de
faire et donc le gros enseignements de
cette expérience c'est le quand les gens
ou le temps d'être confronté à la
description du problème il change d'avis
sur leurs préférences
comment est-ce qu'on change d'une
référence positive et une première
manière de les changer
c'est d'inclure une compréhension d'un
problème qu'on n'avait pas
après vous empêcherez pas les vieux ne
pas avoir exactement les envies des
jeunes les femmes les envies des hommes
les franchisés et bretons les envies et
sabrina enfin
quoi c'est quoi ça
et les urbains les envies d euros donc
on essaye mais ce qui est important
c'est qu'on arrive à ce que la
collectivité
effectivement intègre quelque chose qui
est ou contraintes qui s'imposent à tous
dans l'expression ses préférences ça
c'est difficile
alors empêché du bialé là et là où
j'avais repéré
bonsoir
économique
à mon avis enfin quatre éditions
logiques et la nécessité énormément
d'investissement
et
même en mettant de côté la mauvaise
volonté devoteam y avoir danger ni
financier
tvo dans un monde où il n'ya pas de
france
de décroissance comment
rappelant très puisque lille et doivent
durer six jours
posés par des gestions de pouce d'argent
et des lycées
aussi les investissements si nécessaire
et la logique
alors le poker grande réponse c'est que
tout alors ils viennent dans le discours
sur les actions qui sont à faire en
matière de climat d'abord tout ne passe
pas par des investissements
tout se passe pas par des
investissements il ya les publications
qu'on a fait à carbone 4 il ya
maintenant 6 ou les mois qui s'appelle
faire sa part où on a chiffré le gain
potentiel en émissions au niveau de
l'empreinte carbone d'un individu lié à
un certain nombre d'éléments de
comportement qui ne suppose aucun
investissement alors le premier open
acceptable connaissent consiste à
modifier son régime alimentaire
si on modifie son régime alimentaire
pour manger moins de viande
typiquement on va laisser son empreinte
carbone sur l'alimentation ça ne suppose
aucun investissement aussi
éventuellement vous achetez un cuiseur
vapeur pour les haricots verts des
lotissements quand même assez modeste si
vous avez des comportements vertueux
dans lesquels vous avez des
investissements par exemple si vous
évitez d'acheter une voiture et que vous
achetez un vélo électrique à la place
parce qu'il se trouve que votre voiture
vous a essentiellement pour aller faire
les cons c'est au boulot et que tout ça
et là des ventes de chez vous et c'est
pas un cas de figure fictif ce chantre à
dire parce que l'anglais ben non c'est
typiquement le genre de 3,2 l'aspect
qu'on est en fin de match les points
quand un bon en ce moment ça ne suppose
donc un investissement supplémentaire ça
suppose un désinvestissement en contre
vous aviez une bagnole 5000 euros par an
et aussi vous en 2000 à l'achat elle est
hier en quarts d'entretien sans impacter
grand chose donc l'idée que tous les
comportements qui sont vertueux sur le
plan des émissions passe par des
investissements c'est faux après vous
avez un deuxième
nous avions un deuxième point à voir
c'est que tous les investissements qui
sont affaire ne passe pas nécessairement
par cric
vous avez en particulier où c'est
exactement ne passe pas nécessairement
par un supplément de crise
vous avez actuellement en france chaque
année 50 milliards d'euros de mémoire
qui sont réalisés dans les travées de
lâcher des logements des particuliers
vous pouvez très bien obligés à ce que
ces travaux soient prioritairement
fléchés sur la décarbonation des
bâtiments donc les gens feront moins
d'extinction au pavillon et de chez moi
et ils auront plus d'isolation des
combles et de pompes à chaleur c'est pas
nécessairement quelque chose qui suppose
de dépenser plus par contre vous avez
pas la même chose à l'arrivée les mais
ça nécessite c'est une réorientation des
investissements existants
vous pouvez très bien décider que les
collectivités locales qui ont moins
dépensé une somme coquette en rond point
ces dernières années continue à payer
des gens du btp mais au lieu de leur
demander de rajouté des roaches ont
continué à faire aujourd'hui à leur
demande de rajouter des pistes cyclables
oui donc la notion même de ce que c'est
qu'un investissement qui est pertinent
pour le climat et quelque chose ou la
métrique aujourd'hui extrêmement
imparfaite
parce qu'on arrive pas qu on sait que
les éoliennes on va rajouter en plus
et en fait c'est une vision extrêmement
parcellaires et remonter les problèmes
le vrai sujet c'est de rendre la
totalité des flux d'investissement
compatibles avec la baisse globale des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre lors
un chiffre que je rappelle la campagne
pour ceux qui vont déjà entendu il faut
savoir que la compatibilité avec les
deux degrés de limitation de la hausse
de la température planétaire
actuellement on est à peu près on est à
1 et les incendies qui auront lieu sur
deux points courant sur la planète c'est
la superficie de la france et ainsi leur
ajouter l'australie et la sibérie ce qui
est en train de se passer en californie
on a parlé comme ça où il ya le
changement climatique a joué un rôle
déterminant dans tous et par tous ses
feux alors que vous obtenez la
superficie de la france
ça fait quand même un paquet de millions
d'hectares et nous ne sommes qu'un de m
pour ce qui est des as 2 qu'il faut que
les émissions planétaires baisse
d'environ 4 à 5 % à commencer par deux
en commençant demain 4 à 5% de baisse
c'est ce qu'on va avoir en 2001 grâce
aux corridas retenez un truc très simple
c'est que l'accord de paris pour le
respecter c'est un colis de
supplémentaires par an savoir de candeur
qu'il faut avoir en tête et commencez
par faire de l'efficacité énergétique et
décarbonées l'industrie à la bonne
vitesse
rien qu'avec des améliorations
technologiques peut-être quelqu'un qui
me demander ce que je pense d'eux
l'ayant héros jeunes gens pensent aux
petits enfants sont morts et que nous
accusons pas et applications
commerciales à vidanger fictives le ca
me dire en gros que effectivement on va
devoir se palucher si on fait ça une
économie qui sont entracte de 30% par an
c'est ça que ça veut dire respecter
l'accord de paris c'est en gros une
économie qui se contracte de 3 300 par
an et chez opel était donné à leur
demande donc le caire que dans ce
contexte la contracter des emprunts
supplémentaires on se dit où sera
l'argent pour rembourser
voilà pour effectivement il aura pas
d'argent et c'est très clair qu' une
partie du supplément d'engagement qu'on
a créé depuis 2008 au doublé
dans cette commune on a doublé le têt au
secteur financier exposé je ne vais pas
me tombait donc d'effectivement à un
moment il y aura pas la france et tout
ça alors il ya deux leviers de manière
ne pas rembourser l'argent c'est défaut
et l'inflation alors une variante de
l'inflation si les taux négatifs mais
c'est effectivement
donc si on demande à ce que les gens
empruntent de l'argent pour payer des
investissements qu'on va leur demander
fun on peut leur demander d'en recruter
j'arrive en fête et du reste des banques
pour leur prêter la vocation après c'est
de savoir qui est la part qui sera en
course et insiste sur le fait qu'une
bonne partie des comportements et une
boîte partie des actions de substances
ne suppose pas un supplément d'argent en
circulation
par contre ça suppose pour réoriente
l'affectation de l'argent et ça
aujourd'hui la comptabilité de ce truc
là et les très belles fêtes étaient 130
% de dette du pib de la france
aujourd'hui
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
par liste rené partie on va pas
l'arranger ont fait une clé ravi de
bondy c'est une pyramide de ponzi dont
la rembourse en gros ce qu'on a fait
c'est depuis que la tête a commencé à ce
prêt à se creuser entre les champs
pétroliers c'est que l'on à rembourser
la dette
arrosez le principal et les intérêts en
s'entêtant plus c'est exactement le
principe du car a dit devant tout
historiquement on voit que les états qui
ont commencé à rembourser leurs dettes
pour la stabilité de leur monnaie
leurs critiques qui disent si votre
question c'est est-ce que tu ici est-ce
que je meurs je vais vivre dans un banc
de sable là je vous réponds tout de
suite on va devenir progressivement de
plus en plus instable foncière à cette
idée donc ça veut dire que les plans de
transition qui flottent sont des plans
qui flotte dans un monde qui va devenir
de plus en plus instable alors
heureusement c'est une donnée du
problème
faut pas s'imaginer que demain la
stabilité va revenir et c'est pas une
seconde
les facteurs de déstabilisation de
fortifier donc le monde va être de plus
en plus instable
alors heureusement il y avait une
question ou fous là bas
[Musique]
non il a été question du betty son
programme non c'était le sens que
c'était une personne à l'avant-dernier
rang le non non on va vous dérange pas
après on passera à monsieur laquelle on
pose des questions par rapport à
aujourd'hui on compte beaucoup en
prostatique reprend sa part dit pour
l'améliorer alors y à paris alors
effectivement arrêter de manger des
burgers ça sert à quoi
30% les émissions de paris c'est l'avion
courant alors que ya d'autres gens dit
dans mon fils rouges et l'envoyer
champenois
son passe temps à me taire
dix ans et hong kong
et nos enfants
et ce long terme de population voici
une tension un autre mobiliser pour
sortir des régions
oui
alors
devant j'ai les purs en alsace avec lima
castillan
oui alors est ce que les gens ne
devraient pas bouger et c'est ça la
question
alors c'est quand on lit malthus
il explique les invasions barbares
enfin que nous on appelle les invasions
barbares aujourd'hui je construis des
scandinaves se considère le point du
double des barbares
les accessoires m'en donner un roaa
défense par le fait qu'il y avait un
excellent population par rapport à la
capacité à va nourrir sur place on peut
très bien imaginer effectivement qu'avec
le changement climatique ya des zones
qui deviennent désagréables et donc les
gens vont bouger pour aller se fait
d'ailleurs le problème c'est que on est
déjà comme un gros coup sur terre les
milliards et les ailleurs il ya personne
et les conditions sympathiques sont
rares alors ou bien il ya actuellement
des conditions déjà sympathique et très
content de voir arriver en masse eh bien
il ya absolument personne
et à ce moment il ya six mois je passe
truculent donc ça veut dire que les
endroits où les gens arrivent on est à
poil
il n'y a pas eu groupe pas il décolle
pas la tour inqualifiable
et pas la trésorerie paierie générale
est aussi très agréable donc et rien et
en gros et sauf que peu de gens vont
accepter d'aller livrer quelque part et
c'est à dire on va faire comme les
indiens avec le 3 de bois est investi
sur donc l'idée qu'on va déplacer des
populations de manière significative
pour résoudre le problème sans que ça du
tout en conflit est évidemment une idée
qu eric et on ne souscrit pas mais par
contre on va avoir des migrations alors
des migrations vais les avoir il ya dans
les avancées scientifiques récentes
moyen de deux qui m'ont frappé il y en a
une qui est sorti ya pas très longtemps
disant que dans un réchauffement de 4
degrés il ya entre 1,5 et 3 milliards
d'individus qui vivraient dans des zones
où ils vivent actuellement qui
deviendrait plus chaude que le sahara
on peut l'imaginer qui ne croyais à
rester et en général quand ça concerne
des volumes aussi important il va pas
très loin ils vont regarder leurs
voisins ça c'est de proche en proche
donc ça veut dire que ces régions là
vont devenir progressivement de plus en
plus adverse pour que les gens puissent
se nourrir est évidemment de plus en
plus conflictuelle c'est absolument
absolument c'est ça que ça va donner en
fait c'est pas tellement plus simple et
moins
vous important c'est que c'est que ça
plus en plus concepteur après il ya un
autre truc qui font garder en tête c'est
que le réchauffement repoussant les
pôles les zones qui sont éventuellement
favorable nous vivons sur une sphère
n'aura pas échappé que la terre est
ronde et la géométrie boutique quand
vous prenez une bande comprise entre de
latitude et que vous la remontée vers
les pôles diminuer la surface de la
vente corps de la juriste du matin et
donc si vous voulez faire tenir autant
de monde sur une bande d'une plus petite
surface avec beaucoup moins de terres
cultivables
on me dit qu'à un moment ça risque de
coincer humble donc il est absolument
évident pour moi que le problème ne se
résoudra pas par des migrations de masse
pacifique
ça se résoudra ça va créer une pression
migratoire ça c'est absolument certain
mon sentiment c'est que nous n'en avons
vu que le début le dernier point c'est
aujourd'hui le pétrole c'est à dire le
commerce internationale d'une part et la
capacité à avoir une agriculture très
productive dans certaines eaux d'autre
part à permet de rééquilibrer la
disponibilité alimentaire mondiale c'est
à dire que là où ça pousse pas vous
pouvez faire venir de grands dangers
quand même grâce au pétrole les moyens
de transport les grâce au pétrole et au
gaz
les emplois et et rappeur parce que
c'est très productif ailleurs le jour où
domine plus cette marge de manoeuvre
pour avoir une agriculture aussi
productives les capacités d'exportation
un certain nombre de pays dans
s'affaiblir et donc les capacités à se
nourrir d'un certain nombre de pays qui
dépendent au premier rang des
importations donc les pays
j'ai envie de dire proche de la bande
conjugale avec une cote de lévis
démographie en croissance rapide
c'est évident que dans ces endroits là
c'est dès février en puissance donc le
la raison pour laquelle il y avait trois
baies noires
en plus quelques dizaines de millions de
de gens dans la péninsule arabique c'est
grâce à ça c'est parce qu'on a fait
venir la nourriture dont vous rassure
c'est donc le la question des questions
de la disponibilité alimentaire un
moment ou un autre ça va finir quand
même pas rendre toute cette histoire de
reprendre population un peu désagréable
j'ai pour cela mais je voulais savoir où
en était le chiffre project par les
politiques français quels sont les
niveaux chapeau alors là dessus on a
largement on a largement communiqué donc
peut-être que je vais botté en touche on
est en pro dans le club en gros on est
ronde et eau
vous faites donc un ensemble de
d'un plan de transformation de
l'économie française en gros de fer
l'embryon de notre programme
présidentiel idéal c'est un peu ça au
début on voulait faire quelque chose qui
était une réponse rapide les meilleurs
faire la bergère au moment du plan de
relance
en fait on s'est rendu compte qu'on
serait totalement des clous en termes de
délais si on voulait faire un peu au
sérieux et donc on a décidé de
transformer ça en main boulot sérieux
recours est donc il va sortir entre dans
pas longtemps et le printemps vous
donnez le 22 ans fin janvier 2022 donc
on va on n'a qu'à danser sur tous les
autres et on espère un succès le débat
en l'ensemble un nombre de ballons
d'essai et en espérant qu'ils
participeront de la discussion
voilà où on en dénombre aux visas vis du
monde politique français
je crois qu'il y avait une question là
une question lancinante et bord elles
sont un lieu non pas demain
merci de votre
une question
toutefois près du vin d'accord j'ai une
question
sur le
une action dans le tycoon
poissy et depuis tout ce temps
comment on est sur les besoins de base
de l'occidental moyen dans un grand
chantier par là on est en train
d'essayer d'y travailler
aujourd'hui je vais vous répondre en
termes de moyens mis dans cette question
plus qu'en termes de réponse à la
question
d'abord il faut vraiment millions à
d'occidentaux ensuite il faudra savoir
ce qu'on appelle les moyens de base
est-ce que c'est l'alimentation qui
beaucoup de 10% de ce que vous gagnez
vous arrivez à angers même avec
l'alimentation qui vous coûte les deux
tiers de ce que vous gagnez comme
c'était le cas il ya deux siècles de
l'épreuve comptant un dossier que ses
dessins il ya deux siècles
l'alimentation food les deux tiers de
ses revenus en mangeant cinq fois moins
de viande par personne qu'aujourd'hui le
donc là la question c'est qu'il faut y
réfléchir par contre ça c'est sûr
aujourd'hui il ya une réflexion
organisée sur ce genre de question qui
est extrêmement faible sinon inexistante
c'est inaudible pour une large partie du
monde de la recherche de se situer dans
un dirigenats contraint à ce point là
donc la seule voie de réponse que je
puisse vous faire c'est en y
réfléchissant alors qui doit y réfléchir
doit faire réfléchir les gens qui sont
dans le monde de la recherche technique
par exemple les agronomes devrait
consacrer une partie des forces vives de
l'inra à se demander comment est ce
qu'on fait pour continuer à produire de
la nourriture dans un monde dans lequel
le climat a été modifié et des moyens
énergétiques disponibles sont moins
importants
il faut commencer par faire ce travail
pour avoir une idée de ce que petrov
vous avez une recherche à faire du côté
économique parce que les modes de
régulation qui permettent de sauver car
j'ai les pratiques apicoles vertueuse
pour faire face à ce problème sont
éventuellement différente de celle que
vous avez aujourd'hui leur jeu vous
donner un exemple si aujourd'hui vous
voulez faire émerger les pratiques
agricoles qui sont pertinentes pour
intégrer la contrainte environnementale
en général elles vont économiquement
vous coûter plus cher que les pratiques
actuelles
donc vous ne pouvez pas les faire
émerger c'est une protégée pas les
acteurs en question la conférence
internationale je vous pouvez pas faire
donc ça veut dire que vous avez besoin
de modifier l'organisation des systèmes
de distribution et de commercialisation
d'un point de vue strictement règlement
d'air aussi parce que sinon à aucun
moment vous pourrez faire émerger ce qui
nous intéressera un peu plus tard voilà
que vous avez plein de vous avez une
réflexion entamée chez les mureaux
parce qu'ils ont beaucoup de mal à se
projeter dans un avenir demain
avant terme et sera donc en fait c'est
une question qui appartient quelque part
à beaucoup de gens qui doivent se donner
un cahier des charges qui est compatible
avec ce qu'on sait de l'évolution du
climat et l'évolution de la
disponibilité énergétique et l'évolution
de la fertilité des sols enfin tous ces
trucs et qui derrière doivent regarder
comment est ce qu'on arrive à optimiser
au mieux tout ça
qu'est ce qu'on est capable de faire à
ce moment là cela étant si la réponse
est en dedans 50 ans sachant que nous
sommes un peuple à 450 millions
d'européens l'europe avec beaucoup moins
de pétrole et intime a modifié est
capable de nourrir 200 millions de
personnes faisait au fait qu'il n'ya pas
nécessairement de ré ya pas une réponse
simple à cette question là par contre
une direction dans laquelle partir pour
comprendre comment avancer que ça c'est
sûr aujourd'hui un grand regret cette
érection est très peu emprunté parce que
vous avez encore énormément de gens qui
notre boîte à la déstabilisation à venir
du monde alors pouvoir se la voir dans
le monde agricole
parce que la france 2 seront des
sécheresses à répétition et un monde
fort ici commence à voir les arts
premiers
là le commence à se réveiller et c'est
trop tard enfin c'est comme ça c'est
trop tard pour faire quelque chose ce
sera quelqu'un dise ferrières en mai il
ya pas tellement d'autres choses à faire
que ce que je faisais je portais pas les
mêmes questions
bonsoir je filme mauvais mois en fin
d'année sur ce sujet donc j'en profite
cette agression nous pour vous à quoi
ressemblerait en interne est compatible
avec les accords de paris en interne est
moins énergivore et à ce que l'on pense
et internet pourrait disparaître un jour
à cause des limites à nevers à la 2 e
vous savez question est très facile par
écrit n'importe quand on entre
maintenant et dentelle avec 5 milliards
d'années
c'est sûr que ça disparaîtra un jour là
la réponse à la première question elle
doit se pour moi il doit s'apprécier en
termes de dynamique est pas en termes
d'objectifs finale sur je ne sais pas
vous dire à quoi ressemble internet dans
50 ans si on a correctement décarbonés
l'économie il faudra manquer
par contre je sais vous dit avant quatre
directions il faut partir demain matin
si on veut être compatible avec la
direction à prendre je répète c'est
moins 5% par an pour les émissions
planétaires dont reste d'une manière
générale à résoudre le problème du
changement climatique suppose toujours
de renverser la hiérarchie des critères
qu'on entend respecter aujourd'hui
hiroshi des critères c'est d'abord je
m'occupe de l'économie qui ensuite s'il
reste de la place
est ce que je peux faire sur vic sur
l'environnement d'abord je m'occupe du
social puis ensuite s'il reste de la
place je m'occuperai de l'environnement
d'abord je m'occupe du commerce
international qui ensuite s'il reste de
la place qu'occupera de l'environnement
est d'abord je m'occupe d'augmenter les
débits et ensuite s'il reste de la place
donc si clair que si on veut que
l'internet soit compatible accords de
paris dans une logique un peu communiste
et avance à 14,5 à tout le monde
à ce moment votre critère c'est qu'est
ce que je peux garder si je fais moins 5
% tous les ans soit la bonne question
alors ce qui est sûr c'est que la
direction dans laquelle ça nous oblige à
partira pas raisonnablement court terme
c'est des appareils que vous allez
garder plus longtemps donc avoir aidé
dit qu'il va être moins vite
l'important inventé des appareils qui
baissent en performance mentale parce
que en gros ce qui coûte dans un truc
comme ça c'est fabriqué l'écran est
fabriqué l'électronique le micro
processeur et mémoire
processeur sans fil est donc ça veut
dire des trucs qui ont des performances
un peu dégradée enfin moi pour faire de
l'excellent france où la résolution 25
cas ça veut dire des débiles qui
n'augmente plus
voir kim est ce pour tout ce qui est
communication de données voilà en gros
et surtout ça veut dire qu'on n'en
rajoute pas donc ça veut dire qu'on va
pas rendre votre masque de midi quant
aux pentes osseux communicante
autre genre communicants aujourd'hui on
en rajoute encore et toujours
tous ces trucs là évidemment une réalité
matérielle est vendu clairement un
terrain alors je ne sais pas si je dois
vous dire je vous rassure ou au
contraire je vous inquiète c'est
absolument pas la direction dans
laquelle on parle aujourd'hui il est
toujours dans d'abord c'est très
important que les gens puissent avoir la
singette réfléchir à savoir si c'était
une bonne idée le si on voulait être
sérieux sur cette question djoudi ont
réservé un bon sens pourtant fait on
attendra les autres ingénieurs de faire
un don très classique d'optimisation sur
4,1 l'an dernier le contrat indépassable
sépare 5% par an trouvez moi est ce que
vous pouvez me trouver le lieu dans le
cadre de cette contrainte
c'est assez rigolo ça veut dire aussi
que sur les formes contractuels pour
finir ça vous n'en ai plus
le débit d'une idée nous aurons la
toussaint
et vous n'aurez plus
en gros idéalement il faut pour les
opérateurs de télécoms des terminaux de
guérites chargé pas une source de
profits aujourd'hui c'est une source de
profits parce que j'attendais revendus
aux manettes de téléphone l'opérateur
qui marche dans l'opération pour vous
fait payer de soissons téléphone coupés
dans l'événement est cependant pas
gratuite et une marge au moment où nous
vend le téléphone donc pour lui le
téléphone est un centre de profit est ce
qu'il faut c'est arrivé à passer à une
forme contractuelle pour lui c'est une
charge ce qui vous rend service et tout
ce qui contribue à l'élaboration du
service elle coûte de l'argent
le débit illimité ils sont assez pour
les opérateurs aujourd'hui afin de
donner vite et arrêter ça parce que
justement comme cette immunité doivent
investir en permanence pour augmenter
les performances du réseau lors qu'il ya
pas plus d'argent ça c'est typiquement
un truc ou quand on est déçu
cinq ans si j'envoie super transition en
plus puisque maxime d'amendements dont
parlait de l'impact environnemental du
numérique et des travaux les shifts sur
le sujet
[Applaudissements]